Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 268, wo wir heute über Attribution reden wollen. Wer war's gewesen? Und zwar beim Einbruch in digitale Systeme. Das wollen wir heute besprechen und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich. Einerseits aus dem Clubumfeld könnte man sagen Vollkorn, auch einer der Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club, arbeitet in der IT Security. Hallo und guten Abend. Wolpertwo, der in der sogenannten Incident Response arbeitet, auch das IT Security. Weitestens dann kann man vielleicht noch genauer erklären, was eine Incident Response ist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo zusammen.
Und Hakan Tanriverdi, ein Journalist derzeit vor allem, und ich glaube ausschließlich beim Bayerischen Rundfunk, immer mit Themen zu tun haben, die auch in die Richtung Digitales zeigen. Hallo und guten Abend. Und gerade einen Podcast veröffentlicht haben, der sich genau mit dieser Frage beschäftigt, wenn auch in einem bisschen weiteren Kontext. Dazu sind wir heute tatsächlich sozusagen, das ist der Anlass, warum wir heute mal zusammengekommen sind, um über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Und wenn man in der Vergangenheit über dieses Thema gesprochen... Nee, stopp, halt. Liebe alle, mir ist bei der Vorbereitung eine Sache aufgefallen, und zwar, dass wenn erklärt wird, was Attribution ist, dann wird mittlerweile unironisch gesagt, es handelt sich dabei herauszufinden, wer Cyberangriffe verursacht hat oder Angriffe im Cyberraum passiert sind. Ab wann haben wir eigentlich aufgehört, Cyber als ironisches Tag zu benutzen, sondern als ernstzunehmendes Wort? Oder bin ich da in einer Fehlwahrnehmung aufgesessen?
Also ich glaube, da muss man einmal sich kurz klarmachen, nach welchen Prämissen und Prinzipien zum Beispiel Nachrichtendienste arbeiten und nach welchen Ermittlern, die Polizei und so weiter, nach welchen die arbeitet. Für den Nachrichtendienst geht es nicht darum, etwas gerichtsfest klarzumachen. Die Nachrichtendienst hat andere Aufgaben. Der muss aufklären, der muss sagen, nach unserem Dafürhalten passiert XYZ, da läuft eine Operation. Die wird statt dem manntwegen Russland, USA, Israel, wie auch immer zugewiesen. Und wir sagen das mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von so und so viel Prozent. Diese Prozentzahlen sind bei Nachrichtendiensten fast schon so hard codiert mit, wie sicher etwas ist. Wenn sie sagen 95 bis 99 Prozent, dann ist das das Maximale, was man von denen bekommen wird. Mehr haben die nicht, mehr wollen die auch nicht. Und damit sie an diesen Punkt kommen können, ist es selten der Fall, ich habe hin und wieder mit solchen Leuten geredet, aus europäischen Nachrichtendiensten oder generell westlichen, die gesagt haben, pass auf, wir verlassen uns nie nur auf technische Indizien, wir haben auch Signals Intelligence, das heißt, wir schauen, was die Hacker machen, indem wir sie hacken oder wir haben Human Intelligence, das heißt, wir haben Quellen vor Ort, die uns gewisse Sachen anderweitig bestätigt haben. Und dann haben sie so einen ganzen Baukasten an Prinzipien, nach denen sie am Ende sagen, wie sicher sind wir uns? Eine kriminalistisch arbeitende Behörde wie das Bundeskriminalamt, die wird natürlich sagen, was sind unsere rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien? Die funktionieren so, dass wir am Ende sagen müssen, hier ist die Tat, hier ist der Täter. Und die müssen dann zum Staatsanwalt und der Staatsanwalt geht damit zum Richter und der Richter unterzeichnet das dann oder nicht. Und das ist das, was wir rechtsstaatlich nennen. Und genau, und in solchen Fällen kann ich sagen, ist es gerichtsfest ab der Sekunde, wo es halt zu einem Verfahren kommt und diese Person verurteilt würde.
Aber das klingt für mich schon mal so, dass die das jetzt sagen, also allein aus dem, was Täter in einem System hinterlassen oder was man ihnen sagen nachführen kann, lässt sich das nicht so sicher sagen. Und was mich jetzt noch sozusagen bei Vollkorn und Wolpertwo interessieren würde, ist, Hakan hat jetzt erklärt, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einer nachrichtendienstlichen Bewertung und einer juristischen Bewertung. Wie ist es denn in der IT-Security? Ich würde tippen eher so, wie die Nachrichtendienste das machen.
Ja, das würde ich auch sagen. Also wenn ich so ein Report schreibe, wo ich sage, wir haben folgende Dinge entdeckt, dann schreiben wir vielleicht noch ein Summary dazu, also eine Kurzzusammenfassung, wo dann sagt, okay, es deutet darauf hin, aber wir sagen eigentlich nie, wir sind uns hundertprozentig sicher. Weil wir führen dann auch üblicherweise an, an welchen Stellen, also wie viel Aussagekraft das hat. Also zum Beispiel haben wir dann immer noch gleich eine Relativierung, die dann sagt, das könnte aber auch ein gefälschtes Indeed sein oder Ähnliches. Also da sind wir auch sehr vorsichtig, weil uns ganz klar ist, zum einen, dass nämlich wir zum Beispiel bei dieser Untersuchung nur einen Ausschnitt der Informationen gefunden haben und andere Informationen einfach übersehen haben, die ein ganz anderes Bild zeichnen würden. Das kann passieren. Es kann sein, wie wir schon besprochen haben, dass da Volts-Flag-Operationen jetzt im Spionagebereich oder aber auch ganz einfache Verschleierungsaktionen, wie zum Beispiel man mietet sich als Angreifer oder Angreiferin einen Server im Ausland, wo man gar nicht sitzt und geht da rüber. Und dann kann man schon wieder ein paar Informationen haben, wo man jetzt nicht weiß, okay, ist das jetzt wirklich dem Angreifer zuzuordnen oder der Angreiferin oder ist das was anderes? Also da muss man schon sehr vorsichtig sein und ganz klar auch sagen, wie viel Aussagekraft die Sachen, die man hat, entdeckt hat, wirklich haben. Und die Antwort ist üblicherweise nichts Exaktes, nichts hundertprozentiges, sondern immer so ein, wir haben recht viele Indizien, die dies sagen, es ist wahrscheinlicher, dass es jenes ist als solches, aber kein festes, das ist es definitiv.
Ich möchte aus den ganzen Merkmalen, die ihr aufgezählt habt, mal eins rausgreifen, das ist nicht dieses, weil du es gerade auch noch mal sagt, das nicht sich einen Server mieten. Also es gibt das Prinzip der IP-Adressen, also Rechner, die im Netz sind, haben eine Nummer, über die man sie identifizieren kann. Und da würde ich ja denken, das ist ja wirklich das allerkleinste Ein-mal-eins, die, wenn ich irgendwo angreife, dass ich natürlich nicht, dass der dann nicht die IP sieht von dem DSL-Anschluss von zu Hause, sondern dass ich dann einen sozusagen einen VPN benutze, also ein Netzwerk, wo ich dann erst mal in ein anderes Land vielleicht sogar gehe. Das heißt, gibt oder was ist die Frage dahinter eigentlich? Ich muss kurz mich zusammenfassen und überlegen. Die Frage dahinter ist, glaube ich, also konkret sind sowas wie IP-Adressen überhaupt von Relevanz bei den Ermittlungen und ein bisschen weitergefasst. Gibt es mittlerweile digitale Dinge, von denen man sagt, also ja, die könnten theoretisch ein Merkmal sein, aber die sind einfach so leicht zu fälschen, das müssen wir uns nicht mal angucken.
Ich komme mir vor, wie ein Rechtsbelehrungspodcast. Also beispielsweise, wenn man gerade auch mit Leuten, die eben solche Angriffe simulieren, was so auf Neudeutsch-Recht-Team-Angriffe redet oder halt auch mit Leuten auf der Offensive kommt oder so, die beschweren sich auch immer darüber, dass sie halt irgendwie skalieren müssen, dass sie ihre Internetinfrastruktur pflegen müssen. Und wenn dann natürlich Täter einen Opfer mit letztlich derselben Software, derselben Infrastruktur angreifen, dann kann natürlich die IP-Adresse sehr viel wert sein, wenn man es mit Profis zu tun hat, die wirklich probieren, was dann wieder das nächste Schlagwort wäre, Compartmentalization, die dann halt wirklich probieren, für jeden eine eigene Verwertungskette bestehend aus Werkzeugen, aus Internetinfrastruktur aufzubauen. Dann sind natürlich die IP-Adressen weniger wert. Aber das Schöne ist auch, wenn Angreifer erfolgreich sind einmal, dann machen ihre Chefs nun mehr Druck, dass sie mehr Erfolg haben und dann müssen sie nur noch mehr skalieren. Das heißt also, es gibt immer so paar Merkmale, wo dann halt Täter sagen, dass sie dann eben auch Kompromisse machen oder aber, weil sie auch, wenn sie aufgeklärt haben, werden gar kein Risiko befürchten, weil sie gar nicht vorhaben, ihr Land zu verlassen. Dann spielen natürlich IP-Adressen, Prüf-Summen eben immer noch eine Rolle. Sie sind halt heutzutage vielleicht ein bisschen weniger übertragbar geworden, weil halt die meisten Täter halt mittlerweile wissen, wie sie ihre Melker so schreiben, dass die halt jedes Mal eine andere Prüf-Summe hat. Aber auch der eine oder andere wird auch sagen, okay, ich greife Ziele an, die sind so schlecht gesichert, da mache ich mir die Mühe ja nicht. Und von daher, ja, ich glaube, das Problem heutzutage besteht immer darin, wenn die Täter halt Zugriff auf entweder Open Source Hacking Software haben oder auch einfach Raubkopien und dann einfach alle dieselben Werkzeuge verwenden. Dann kann man natürlich mit der Tatsache, dass der Täter das Werkzeug X verwendet, kann man nichts anfangen, wenn das schlichtweg alle anderen auch machen. Und das ist auch sehr angenehm für die Täter, weil dann können sie sich vor als Flag-Operationen sparen.
Eine Anmerkung vielleicht noch auf IP-Adressen bezogen unter diesen Leuten, die in dem Bereich Forensik und Threat Intelligence, also herausfinden, wer hinter diesem Angriff steckt, gibt es diese Pyramid of Pain, was im Wesentlichen bedeutet, wie schwer, wie einfach ist es und wie wertvoll sind manche Informationen. Und IP-Adressen sind relativ weit unten, weil sie vergleichsweise wertlos sind. Aber je weiter du zur Spitze dieser Pyramide kommst, dann geht es plötzlich um diese Tools, die du einsetzt. Und um ein Beispiel zu nennen dieser russischen Gruppierung, die ich genannt hatte, Tula, was die machen ist, die haben ihre ausgespähten Daten teilweise über Satelliten abgestrahlt. Und das kannst du einfach nicht fälschen, weil es nur gewisse Nationen gibt, die die Fähigkeiten haben, Daten über Satelliten abzustrahlen und aufzufangen und dann vor Ort zu entschlüsseln. Dann ist natürlich klar, das muss eine nachrichtendienstliche Behörde sein, ob das dann wirklich diese Gruppe war, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber alleine durch die Tools, die man wählt, gibt man sich auch ein Stück weit Preis. Wenn jetzt alle sagen, wir verwenden nur noch Cobalt Strike, was so ein Angriffswerkzeug ist, das auch sehr viel als Robokopie eingesetzt wird oder gecrackt, dann kann man es nicht mehr machen, weil es alle einsetzen.
Also ein Aspekt auf der anderen Seite ist bei einer IP-Adresse zum Beispiel, die ist zwar für so eine Attributierung wertlos, aber in so einer forensischen Analyse kann das schon wieder ein sehr interessantes Merkmal sein, weil wenn man eine IP-Adresse hat, von der man weiß, von hier aus ging jetzt ein Angriff auf das System, das ich mir gerade anschaue, dann suche ich doch mal in all den Log-Dateien meines Systems, ob ich die IP-Adresse noch finde. Dann ist das nämlich ein sogenannter Indicator of Compromise und der hilft einem super, dann wieder weiter sich aufzufächern und weiter zu gucken, wo denn noch diese Angreifer oder Angreiferinnen gewesen sein könnte in meinem System. Oder ich könnte die auch veröffentlichen und sagen, hey Leute, guckt doch alle mal, habt ihr von dieser IP-Adresse irgendwelche komischen Pakete empfangen? Guckt doch mal da rein. Also, das hilft mir wenig bei der Attribution direkt, aber es ist ein gutes Merkmal, um weiter zu suchen, was denn noch alles irgendwo gewesen sein könnte.
Okay, also kann mir sozusagen tatsächlich ein bisschen bei der Aufarbeitung helfen. Jetzt haben wir das abstrakte und theoretisch besprochene Hakan. Also, ihr habt den ganzen Podcast zugemacht, aber kannst du kurz zusammenfassen, welcher Fehler oder welche Dinge dazu geführt haben, dass man sich da, ich formuliere es mal nachrichtendienstlich, relativ sicher ist, wer das war?
Kann ich gerne machen. Und zwar einmal etwas, was sehr, glaube ich, vielen Leuten sofort einleuchtet, ist der Hacker, um den es geht. Der hat Google Mail verwendet, was ich persönlich bis heute einfach crazy finde, aber so war das anscheinend. Und über Google Mail kommen halt die amerikanischen Behörden und sagen, hey, Google, gib uns bitte dieses Postfach, hier ist der Richter, der unterschrieben hat, hier ist das Dokument, das du uns bitte übergeben musst. Google übergibt denen das Postfach, sie geben das an die Deutschen weiter später und dann findet man halt da relativ viel über diesen Menschen drin, so wie in euren E-Mail-Accounts auch wahrscheinlich sehr viele persönliche und private Informationen sind. Das war der eine Teil. Und der zweite Teil ist, dass der Typ, in der Chart-Software, die er programmiert hat, hat er vergessen, einen Dateipfad zu löschen. Das ist PDB nennt sich das und das sind im Wesentlichen Debugging-Informationen. Also du schreibst Software und dieses Software, dieses Programm sagt dir, pass auf, in Zeile so und so ist ein Fehler, der dafür sorgt, dass es folgende, dass deine Funktion nicht genau ausgeführt wird. Oder wie auch immer. So eine Hilfestellung für Programmiererinnen. Und in diesem Detailpfad war sein Kürzel enthalten. Also ich weiß nicht, wie eure Rechner heißen. Wenn mein Rechner heißen würde, Hakan's MacBook Pro, würde in diesem Detailpfad stehen, 10 Doppelpunkt, Hakan's MacBook Pro. Und sowas stand bei ihm auch drin. Und dann haben die Mittel halt geguckt, okay, können wir dieses Pseudonym auf eine Person zurückführen über etwas besseres Googlen.
Also, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, dass es dann sozusagen so einfach ist. Also ist natürlich nicht, man muss die Software auseinandernehmen und dann reingucken sozusagen. Aber wow, ist das einfach was passiert?
Also Fehler, die passieren, sind tatsächlich die Durchbrüche üblicherweise bei so einer Attributierung. Also wenn man irgendwie dann mal feststellt, ach hier, diese Angriffserver, den wir jetzt gerade identifiziert haben, wer hat den denn angemietet? Und dann guckt man eben nach und stellt fest, wie Hakan schon eben gerade erzählt hat, irgendwie durch juristischen Prozess, hier bitte gib uns die Daten, lieber Anbieter. Oh, da steht ja tatsächlich der Name einer Person drin oder da steht irgendwie eine Behördenadresse aus Moskau drin oder sowas. Dann ist das plötzlich so ein Hinweis, wo man denkt, wow, wie kommen sie da drauf, den hier reinzumachen? Und das sind häufig Fehler, die passieren, weil zum Beispiel Druck da war, weil gedacht wurde, ach, das System, das benutzen wir eigentlich nicht dafür, dann wurde es doch dafür benutzt, irgendwo Kompromisse gemacht wurden, wie Wolpertwo gerade schon mehrfach gesagt hat. Oder irgendwie eine Operation schieflief und mal schnell was eben gemacht werden musste. Und dann sind irgendwie Sachen übersehen worden, die ganz eklatant und offensichtlich sind und gefunden werden.
Ja, und das ist dann eben natürlich auch wieder ein Hinweis dafür, dass es sich eben um jemand handelt, dem das vielleicht gar nicht bewusst war. Und es deutet auch eventuell darauf hin, dass er eventuell gar nicht die Aufsicht oder die Ausbildung gehabt hätte, die ihm gesagt hätte, mach das mal bitte anders. Also das hört sich dann eben wirklich nach etwas an, was maximal auf Skalierung getrimmt wird. Ist ja auch wahrscheinlich so, dass wenn halt direkt oder indirekt der Chef Vladimir Putin ist, dass man ihn nicht mit schöner Mehrwert beeindruckt, sondern eben mit vielen Ergebnissen. Und dass dann eben hier das eher so ist, da wird eben gehackt wie in einem Core-Center. Da laufen eben viele Operationen parallel. Und dann ist dann im Zweifelsfall, wie Vollkorn das gesagt hat, dann ist vielleicht sogar eine permanente Hektik da. Und dann gehen eben solche Sachen schief, weil einfach die Zeit da nicht da ist für die Sorgfalt. Da es ja aber auch irgendwo eine Führung gibt, muss man auch davon ausgehen, dass die Führung so was in Kauf nimmt, dass ihr entweder das Risiko bewusst ist oder es ist ihr nicht bewusst. Es ist so wichtig, den Output zu produzieren, dass das eben komplett in Kauf genommen wird oder untergeht. Also es ist sozusagen dann wirklich eher Supermarkt hacken, als halt irgendwie was Schönes sehr auf das Ziel zugeschnitten ist.
Das klingt nicht schön. Das klingt nicht so, als sollte man für solche Chefs arbeiten. Aber gut, was mich da gerade frage ist, wenn also eine der Hauptgründe, wie man den Leuten auf die Spur kommt, der Stress ist, den sie ausgesetzt sind, was macht man eigentlich, wenn man so jemanden im System findet? Also im Sinne von man findet ein kompromiertes System und will dann unter Umständen wissen, wer das ist. Lässt man den dann noch drin und macht ihm das Leben schwer, um ihm eben Stress auszusetzen oder ist eigentlich die Regel immer, wir machen jetzt zu und dann gucken, was übrig bleibt?
Das kommt, glaube ich, ein bisschen darauf an, wie die Situation aussieht. Man redet da häufig immer von Sichtbarkeit. Wenn man den Täter in einem sehr großen Netz findet und groß ist da schon relativ, also auch 1000 Rechner können ganz schön unübersichtlich sein, dann ist ja zu befürchten, dass das letztlich nur die Spitze des Eisberges ist. Also nehmen wir an, wir haben ein Netz mit irgendwie 1000, 2000 Rechnern. Es gibt vielleicht nicht mal eine große Truppe von Administratoren. Man ist eben auf sozusagen irgendwie externe Services angewiesen, die auch dann beauftragt werden müssen. Also wenn man mal 30 Notebooks braucht, dann passiert das nicht schnell schnell, sondern dann muss erst der externe beauftragt werden. Dann muss er erst vorbeikommen. Dann hat man ein bisschen ein Problem, weil dann weiß man dieses Netz ist wahrscheinlich an sich unsicher und ich habe jetzt den Angreifer zufällig an dieser Stelle gefunden. Und dann kommt es eben ein bisschen auch darauf an, was da gemacht wird. Also kann man aus Betriebsgründen überhaupt abschalten? Also gerade in der Industrie kann man Produktionsprozesse nicht unterbrechen, weil das sind halt relativ große Maschinen, die müssen dann eben durchlaufen. Dann haben die Kunden eben natürlich auch ein Anrecht auf Sachen. Das spielt dann eben alles eine Rolle, wie man handeln kann oder nicht.
Aber die Frage, die ich stelle, ist eigentlich eine strategische. Deswegen lasse ich mich sozusagen für die theoretische Diskussion umformulieren. Wenn ich die Wahl habe, zwischen den Zugang, den die TäterInnen haben, abschneiden oder nicht, mache ich das dann sofort? Oder ist es sozusagen in manchen Fällen eine Validüberlegung, zu sagen, na ja, lass mal gucken, was die noch so anstellen? Oder lass mal den Zugriff irgendwie einengen und gucken, ob sie dann einen Fehler machen.
Also ich kann da ein Beispiel aus der Regierung nennen. 2018 gab es einen Angriff auf das Auswärtige Amt und die haben die erstmal machen lassen. Einerseits lässt du die machen, weil du wissen willst, wo sind die eigentlich noch? Und wenn du das Gefühl hast, dass du sowohl es mir erzählt und auch in einem anderen Hacking-Vorfall, du willst gucken, an welchen Stellen sind die überall in deinem System? Und wenn du das rausgefunden hast, dann kannst du koordiniert, dann schickst du halt den Mitarbeiterinnen eine E-Mail und sagst, bitte setzt mal euer Passwort, ein neues Passwort muss angelegt werden. Oder du sagst, wenn die im Wochenende sind, nimmst du die entsprechenden Clients, Desktop, PCs oder was auch immer, betroffen ist vom System und tauschst die aus und machst einen Clean Cut und schmeißt die Täter auf eine Art und Weise raus, wo du dir im Nachhinein sicher bist, dass du keine Backdoors übersehen hast. Das kann ein Argument sein dafür, dass du sagst, wir beobachten die erst mal. Und das hat Wolpertwo ja angesprochen, damit du eine bessere Sichtbarkeit hast. Wo sind die überall im System?
Ja, ich denke der wichtigste Faktor zur Entscheidung ist, bin ich mir sicher, dass wenn ich sie beobachte und machen lasse, dass sie mir dabei nicht unter meinem Hintern meine wichtigen Daten klauen. Wenn ich mir da sicher sein kann, weil sie jetzt zum Beispiel gerade nur in irgendwelchen unwichtigen Systemen sind, dann kann man das mal durchaus machen und sie beobachten. Aber die viel häufiger und üblichere Strategie, in meiner Erfahrung ist auf jeden Fall zu sagen, wir schalten jetzt alles ab und gucken uns an, was da noch an Spuren übrig sind und sorgen dann dafür, so schnell wie möglich wieder kontrolliert ein neues, abgeschottetes System hochzufahren, das frei ist von diesem Angreifer.
Ich glaube, ein Problem in der Realität ist auch, dass je nachdem, wer da angegriffen wurde, dass man manchmal gar nicht die Wahl hat, diese Entscheidung zu treffen, wenn man ein sehr großes Netz hat. Nehmen wir mal an, völlig aus der Luft gegriffen, irgendwie so 120.000 Systeme. Von denen sind etwa 50.000 bis 60.000 noch Windows 7, irgendwie 10.000 oder 12.000 sind noch Windows XP, weil das halt Produktion ist. Und in der Produktion kann ich nicht hinkommen und ständig den Leuten die Rechner neu installieren, dann werden die wahnsinnig. Und dort muss ich mir dann wirklich gut überlegen, was ich mache, weil im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich eingreife, bevor ich die nötige Sichtbarkeit habe und eben Sicherheitsmaßnahmen schaffen kann, dazu brauche ich Personal, das muss auch irgendwo herkommen oder freigestellt werden, dann schubse ich den Täter ja nur irgendwo anders hin. Also dessen Interesse erlischt er nicht, weil ich seine ersten zehn Rechner abgeschaltet habe, sondern der wird ja eventuell weitermachen, wie er seinen Auftrag erfüllt hat. Und schlimmstenfalls schäuche ich dann den Gegner sozusagen durch mein komplettes Netz und habe ihn dann auf einmal an fünf Stellen statt an einer. Und das ist dann natürlich auch, was eben der Betrachtung wert ist. Wenn jetzt jemand ein sehr kleines, übersichtliches Netz hat, der sagt, hey, am Wochenende, da können wir einfach mal alles abschalten und in zwei Tagen machen wir wirklich Strecke und kriegen ein paar Probleme, die die Angreifer ausgenutzt haben, die kriege ich in zwei Tagen im Griff, weil ich die richtigen Leute habe. Dann ist das auf jeden Fall ein gangbarer Weg. Ein anderes Problem ist natürlich auch, dass man manchmal, wenn man ein sehr großes Netz hat, die Zielsetzung des Täters kennen muss, weil für den ist ja nicht alles interessant. Also sozusagen der Kantinenplan, der würde ihn eher wenig interessieren. Das heißt also, das komplette Netz ab einer gewissen Größe sicher zu machen, ist absolut unmöglich. Wenn jemand ein Horrorbeispiel sucht, dann muss er sich vorstellen, irgendwie CISO, also Sicherheitschef vom Netzwerk des US Departments of Defense zu sein. Das ist das Verteidigungsministerium, die haben ungefähr eine Million Rechner. Und die macht man einfach nicht sicher, die werden nie sicher sein. Und dann ist es eben sinnvoll, den Angreifer zu beobachten, zu sagen, Moment mal, der interessiert sich nur für das. Also dann sichern wir eben diese 300 Systeme. Und im Rest, na wenn da die Wölfe ein paar Schafe reißen, dann ist auch egal, weil es einfach gar nicht realistisch ist, diese große Struktur eben zu schützen. Und letztlich ist es oft so, das Auftragsbuch des Angreifers, das ist wirklich das Allerwertvollste, weil seine Absicht ja auch sagt, was passiert denn nach dem Angriff? Was hat er vor? Und daraus kann man eben halt gezielte Schutzmaßnahmen ableiten, aber auch Kompensationsmechanismen, die einfach gar nichts mit Technik zu tun haben.
Jetzt ist eine Sache, die man noch machen kann. Und das ist auch was, was in dem Podcast ganz am Ende diskutiert wird, der sogenannte Hackback. Also dass man sich nicht damit zufrieden gibt, den Angreifer aus dem eigenen System zu werfen, sondern auch dessen Infrastruktur zu hacken. Und das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig auf dem Schirm habe, ein zumindest kontroverses Thema. Bevor wir über die politischen Implikationen reden, erstmal technisch. Gibt es ein technisch sinnvolles Ding, zu sagen, hey, lass uns doch einfach kaputt machen, was uns kaputt macht? Oder übernehmen, was uns versucht zu übernehmen?
Also versuchen kann man das auf jeden Fall, keine Frage. Das ist allerdings üblicherweise ein langwieriger Prozess. Die meisten Aktionen laufen über einen längeren Zeitraum. Und man hat nicht so dieses, ah, wir werden angegriffen, ich drücke jetzt auf den Knopf und dann greifen wir zurück an Mechanismus. Sondern da muss man erstmal die Attribution sauber machen. Man muss erstmal unglaublich viele Informationen sammeln, wie wir ja schon die ganze Zeit besprochen haben, sich sicher zu sein. Und dann muss man also eine Möglichkeit finden, an diesen Angreifer oder die Angreiferin ranzukommen.
Kurze Zwischenfrage, wenn du sagst, die Attribution sauber machen. Das wundert mich jetzt wiederum, weil ich kann nachvollziehen, dass es schwierig ist, eine Person, also zu sagen, diese Person war es. Aber ich dachte schon, dass es einfach ist zu sagen, okay, von dem System kommt das.
Genau, dann sind wir jetzt direkt bei dem politischen Problem. Wenn wir jetzt nämlich sagen, wir greifen einfach das System an, das uns angreift, dann greifen wir mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendein unbeteiligtes System an, das gemietet wurde oder gehackt wurde oder ähnliches, um den Angriff als Jump-Hose zu nutzen. Also als irgendein System, das nicht dem Angreifer oder der Angreiferin gehört, sondern einfach nur zur Verschleierung benutzt wird, um den Angriff tatsächlich durchzuführen. Also das ist eine ganz simple Methode, die quasi jede Angreifergruppe im Petto hat. Und dann hast du natürlich als jemand, der diesen Hackback durchführt, das Problem, dass du möglicherweise einem dritten Staat, der überhaupt nichts mit der ganzen Situation zu tun hat, auf die Füße trittst. Und das ist ein politisches Fiasco, das du vielleicht nicht haben möchtest.
Vielleicht ein ganz plastisches Beispiel. Eine mutmaßlich nordkoreanische Gruppe, die in Lazarus genannt wird, die unter anderem Rheinmetall gehackt hat. Die hat einen C2 Server gehabt, das war ein Auktionshaus in Italien. Und wenn du jetzt plötzlich gegen dieses Auktionshaus vorgehst, was können die dafür? Ganz blöd gesagt. Deswegen glaube ich, dass dieses ganze System übernehmen, das funktioniert schon, weil Hackern passieren einfach Fehler, wie ganz normalen WordPress-Block-Admins-Fehler passieren. Die lassen teilweise ihre Webseiten auf und dann kann man die Logs sehen. Man kann verschiedene Shard-Software auseinandernehmen und gucken, wie genau kommuniziert die. Und wenn du ein Nachrichtendienst bist, dann weißt du, ich fingerprinte diese Kommunikation und dann weißt du, von welchen Servern das kommt. Und da bist du schon relativ weit fortgeschritten im grundsätzlichen Verständnis davon. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine Entwicklung, über die man auch offen und ehrlich diskutieren muss und auch transparent diskutieren muss, dass immer mehr Staaten dazu anfangen, dieses ganze digitale Raum, dieses Fähre, dieses Cyberraum sozusagen als permanenten Konfliktzustand betrachten. Das steht bei den USA, glaube ich, auch explizit so in der Strategie drin. Persistent Engagement oder Defending Forward oder wie auch immer, dass dann der korrekte Begriff ist. Das passiert die ganze Zeit. Willst du oder wollen wir als Deutschland an der Stelle da mitspielen, ist eine Diskussion, die geführt wird. Ich glaube, man kann Argumente dafür finden, aber ich sehe auch das Argument, dass Leute sagen, hey, Deutschland ist, vielleicht lacht jetzt der ein oder die andere, aber trotz allem schon vergleichsweise digital. Und machen wir uns damit nicht selbst, schießen uns damit nicht selbst ins Knie, weil sollten wir nicht lieber diese Systeme erst mal sichern, bevor wir hier anderen die Systeme kaputt schießen.
Das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt, den du da ansprichst, aber gar nicht hinten mich auch. Eine Angriffstrategie, so ein Hackback ist ja ein Angriff auch. Die hat immer eine Folge, nämlich, dass man sich Angriffswerkzeuge irgendwie sammeln muss. Und so ein ganz klassisches Angriffswerkzeug, das ist der sogenannte Zero Day, das wurde sicherlich auch schon öfters im Chaosradio erwähnt, eine Sicherheitslücke, die noch nicht öffentlich bekannt ist. Und diese Sicherheitslücke kann man benutzen, um Angriffe durchzuführen, weil es dafür keinen Patch existiert, der sie absichern könnte. Aber wenn jetzt eine solche Sicherheitslücke entdeckt wird, wäre es ja eigentlich viel sinnvoller, wenn wir sagen würden, wir machen das bekannt dem Hersteller, zum Beispiel Microsoft, wenn es in Windows ist oder so was, und die können einen Patch installieren, bauen und diesen austeilen auf alle Systeme. Dann ist mit dem nächsten Update, sind dann alle Systeme sicher, also viele Systeme sicher, nicht jeder spielt ja im Update ein, aber dann haben wir insgesamt eine Welt, auf der alle Systeme sicherer sind. Aber wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen eine Angriffsstrategie fahren, dann wäre es vielleicht ja auch klüger, diese Sicherheitslücke zu suchen, sie aber nicht den Hersteller zu melden und für sich zu behalten, die ganzen Systeme im Netz unsicher zu lassen und diesen Vorteil für sich zu horten. Und das finde ich natürlich eine fatale Strategie für uns alle. Das ist nämlich eine sehr egozentrische Strategie, die eben nicht die Sicherheit des gesamten Internets berücksichtigt und aller Bürger, die das Internet nutzen weltweit. Darum bin ich auch auf jeden Fall der Meinung von Hakan, dass eine defensive Strategie auf jeden Fall die bessere Strategie ist. Die verhindert mich einerseits, dass wir angegriffen werden können und andererseits verbessern wir dadurch auch noch möglicherweise die gesamte Stabilität des Internets.
Ich will kurz auch noch, wenn ich darf, ein Gegenargument bringen. Also Spionat für einen Nachrichtendienst, der hat eine andere Aufgabe. Die Sicherheit des Internets ist jetzt nichts, was im Kriterienkatalog des Bundesnachrichtendienstes stehen würde. Die haben die Aufgabe, Informationen zu beschaffen. Und man kann argumentieren, dass man den BND nicht haben will, dann ist es eine andere Sache. Aber wenn man sagt, wir haben so einen Dienst, dann wird der natürlich Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen, um an diese Informationen zu kommen. Es hat auch Bruno Kahl in diesen Sitzungen im Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium gesagt, da gibt es jedes Jahr eine, die öffentlich ist, dass sie in, ich glaube Zitat, dass sie fremde Strukturen aufklären. Und Spionage hat auch einfach einen Sinn und Zweck, wenn man sagt, man will in Verhandlungen wissen, was die Gegenseite, was ihr eigentliches Ziel ist, um festzustellen, wo die Puffer sind, wo man nachverhandeln kann, dann ist Spionage ein etabliertes, praktisches Verfahren in der internationalen Politik. Und um dieses Gegenargument zu Ende zu führen, wieso sollte das im digitalen Raum nicht gelten? Wieso sollte man das nicht machen dürfen? So kann man das auch sehen, so kann man auch argumentieren, finde ich.
Aber da ist doch derselbe Blindschluss, der immer, wenn sozusagen solche Konzepte vom Analogen ins Digitale übertragen werden, da ist. Nämlich, das Digitale ist halt ein On-Off-Schalter. Also, wenn man sagt, also, in einem Podcast ist das sehr schön beschrieben, höre ich es an, ne? Also, da sieht man Leute, die sagen, na ja, Spionage, ältestes Gewerbe der Welt, das macht man halt so in der Politik. Meine Güte, stell dir mal nicht so an. Das ist sozusagen, was ich da gehört habe. Und das kann man natürlich sagen. Aber jetzt ist natürlich, ne, also wenn James Bond sich den Bart anklebt und in die Botschaft geht und dann in den Marktenkoffer stöbert, dann passiert halt genau das. Wenn wir aber sagen, die digitalen Werkzeuge, um das zu machen, müssten zur Verfügung gestellt werden, passiert genau das, was Vollkorn gesagt hat, dann sind es nämlich, dann sind alle Opfer. Nicht nur die, die das Spiel spielen, sondern alle Menschen. Und das finde ich echt sehr, sehr kurz gedacht. Und mir macht ein bisschen Angst, dass das sozusagen in dieser Verkürzung noch an diesem Punkt, also beim Kontroltreber so gebracht wird.
Ja, das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum eine wichtige Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs ist, dass das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, das BSI hier in Deutschland, das eben auch ganz klar als Aufgabe hat, sich um die Sicherheit von Informationssystemen zu kümmern. Ich meine, das steht im Namen, ne? Dass die eben nicht dem Bundesministerium des Inneren für Inneres unterstellt sind, sein sollen. Denn das Bundesministerium für Inneren hat natürlich da einen Interessenkonflikt. Die haben da andere Vorstellungen, was zum Beispiel Verteidigung nach außen oder Ähnliches angeht als reine Absicherung und reine Defensive Technik. Und wenn die nämlich abhängig wären, dann könnten wir sicherer sein, dass wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel eine Sicherheitslücke melden und da irgendwie das BSI einbeziehen, dass die nicht versuchen, diese Sicherheitslücke unter den Druck ihres Mutterbundesministeriums unter den Tisch zu kehren oder den Teppich zu kehren und für irgendwelche anderen Zwecke zu gebrauchen.
Also das macht es BSI auch nicht, soweit ich weiß. Nur BSI, alles was denen gemeldet wird, wird in diesen Coordinated Disclosure Prozess eingeleitet. Das explizite ist, was macht der Bundesnachrichtendienst, wenn er eine Sicherheitslücke findet, muss er die sofort preisgeben? Und ich kenne die Position des CCC. Ich will nur darauf hinweisen, dass es nicht deren Aufgabe ist. Man kann das komisch finden und schlecht finden, aber es ist nicht deren Aufgabe.
Also die Lektion ist sozusagen, solange wir einen BND haben, haben wir auch Sicherheitslücken, die nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, weil wir einen BND haben.
Das ist deren Originär, das ist eine Klasse, aufzuklären und die werden die Tools verwenden, die ihnen dabei helfen. Man kann natürlich darüber diskutieren, dass man denen sagt, wie es in den USA ist, dass man denen sagt, wenn ihr eine Lücke habt, dann hat die eine Haltbarkeitsdauer, die könnte nicht von heute bis ins Unendliche horten. Irgendwann müsste das wieder Preis geben, das kann man diskutieren, aber wenn der BND irgendwas machen soll, dann wird er das natürlich auch über Sicherheitslücken machen, nicht ausschließlich, da darf ich auch Internetverkehr filtern usw. Kann man alles kritisieren, aber es ist einfach originäre Aufgabe des BND. Das ist alles, was ich sagen will.
Also, kompliziertes Thema, wo man nichts richtig sagen kann und was dann am Ende auch noch hart ins Politische abrutscht, aber auf jeden Fall total spannend ist. Ich will jetzt am Ende das alles noch mal umkippen und fragen, wie man darüber spricht. Wir haben jetzt 1, 5 Stunden grob darüber geredet und haben ein, also nicht ein ganz grobes Konzept, aber sozusagen ein erstes Bild für die Themenlage vielleicht bei den geneigten ZuhörerInnen malen können. Das Spannende finde ich jetzt sozusagen, das ist ja eben sehr komplex, wie redet man denn darüber als jemand, der vom Fach ist? Ich würde die Runde nochmal zuteilen wollen. Und erstmal Vollkorn und Wolpertwo fragen wollen, wenn ihr sowas macht, dann macht ihr das ja wahrscheinlich auch für Firmen. Und Firmen haben ja die Eigenschaft, dass da Leute Entscheidungen treffen, die nicht immer Fachkompetenz innehaben. Und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die, also Vollkorn hat es vorhin erzählt, ihr schreibt so eine Summary, steht dann drin, naja, es ist wahrscheinlich, aber es könnte auch, ha ha ha. Und jetzt könnte ich mir vorstellen, ich muss jetzt das plattklickieren, der Manager sagt so, ich will jetzt wissen wer das war, sag Bescheid hier. Wie kommuniziert man diese Themen so, dass sie verständlich sind, aber trotzdem nicht eben so vereinfacht werden können, dass halt der Manager dann sagen kann, ja der Vollkorn hat gesagt, die Russen waren's.
Oh ja, das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die man echt üben muss. Also das ist mir als auch, also grundsätzlich in der IT-Security hat man häufig die Situation, dass man als Analyst die Tatsachen beschreibt und sagt, ich habe eine IP-Adresse entdeckt, von der ist der Angriff ausgegangen zum Beispiel. Und häufig gibt es dann aber auch die nächsten Instanzen, die dann erst tatsächlich diese Bewertung vornehmen. Also so ein bisschen auch wie zum Beispiel bei einem forensischen Labor von der Polizei. Der Forensiker, der sagt, ah guck mal, ich habe hier Blut gefunden und das Blut gehört nach DNA nur zu dieser Person. Aber der Forensiker wird jetzt nicht sagen, das ist der Mörder. Und ganz häufig ist es bei mir, in meinem Job habe ich auch dann so, dass ich sage, okay, das sind die Fakten, die ich gefunden habe. Und sie sind auf jeden Fall irgendwie mit diesem Angriff verknüpft auf diese Art und Weise. Und jetzt ist es aber dann vielleicht Aufgabe der Polizei zu bewerten, ob sie jetzt sich einen Durchsuchungsbefehl für diesen Server besorgen sollen. Das ist dann zum Glück meistens nicht mehr meine Sache, wo ich gefragt werde. Eine Entscheidung von zum Beispiel Sicherheitsbehörden oder auch von Unternehmen, die dann eine Risikobewertung machen und sagen, okay, wir haben hier jetzt von unseren Analysten die ganzen Faktenlage aufgetürmt bekommen. Und jetzt müssen wir uns entscheiden, der sagt, oh, es könnte gut sein, aber es geht die Situation, wie du gerade beschrieben hast. Und dann werden wir auch sagen, also das mache ich tatsächlich recht häufig, dass ich sage, pass mal auf, ich kann das nicht hundertprozentig sagen. Das, was ich hier in den Report geschrieben habe, ist meine professionelle Meinung. Und die ist halt nicht absolut sicher. Und ihr müsst jetzt für euch eine Risikobewertung machen, was ihr da für eine Aktion oder nicht machen wollt. Und da ziehe ich mich tatsächlich an der Stelle wirklich auch raus, weil ich kann eben genauso wenig wie jemand anderes die hundertprozentige Entscheidung geben.
Also ein Punkt ist auch, dass man da meistens relativ viel kommuniziert, optimalerweise auch eben bevor ein Bericht geschrieben wird, weil gerade Führungskräfte, die sind ja im Zweifelsfall da, auch in Krisen eben Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und die benötigen den Bericht nicht unbedingt, sondern die benötigen eben einfach, also entweder bestimmte Informationen, die sie aus ihren ureigenen Gründen eben brauchen. Oder eben natürlich möchten sie im Zweifelsfall, also gerade wenn das große Unternehmen sind, einfach eine Entscheidung treffen, die für sie das wenigste Risiko bedeutet, was natürlich dann auch nicht immer einfach ist, weil jetzt ist ja die Krise schon eingetreten und das Risiko kann eben niemand mehr wegzaubern. Das ist dann eben tatsächlich so, es ist auch, wenn jemand Schaden nimmt, es ist, wenn jemand ein sogenannter Erstbetroffener ist, dann ist es teilweise wirklich für die Leute extrem gespenstisch, mit welcher Leichtigkeit sich jemand durch das eigene Netz bewegt und vor allem auch, wenn sie sich dann Investitionen angucken. Also man hat ja dann meistens eben dann doch Geld für den Viren-Scanner oder so ausgegeben, für Antiswerm-Lösungen und das stellt sich dann natürlich alles als Fehlinvestition heraus, weil es hat ja nicht funktioniert. Dann muss man eben einfach mit dem Interesse entsprechend umgehen können und entweder sagen, wenn halt natürlich der Angriff sehr lange her ist, dann sind meistens die Spuren, die das Interesse wiedergeben, verfallen. Dann ist es natürlich schwierig zu sagen, dass das eben wahrscheinlich nicht festgestellt werden kann. Oder aber, das ist eben ein guter Punkt, dass man bei seiner Aufklärung ein, auch immer versucht herauszufinden, was wollte denn letztlich der Angreifer stehlen. Weil diese inhaltliche Information, die kann beispielsweise dafür sorgen, dass man sagt eben, guck mal, das hier wurde geklaut. Und auf einmal, wenn man das mit Leuten bespricht, stellt man raus, dass eben 60% der Leute in der Firma wissen, wer in Frage kommt, weil es einfach niemand anderen interessiert. Und das müssen sie einem natürlich nicht sagen. Manchmal haben ja Führungskräfte, die wissen auch, dass es bei manchen Produkten, da treten auch schon ohne Spionage, treten Klonprodukte auf. Wenn man in bestimmte Länder exportieren will, gibt es Schwierigkeiten. Man bekommt gewisse Genehmigungen nicht. Die Konkurrenz macht auf Messen, macht irgendwie komische Sprüche. Mitarbeiter werden abgeworben. Dann ist es dann manchmal so, dass es dann eben sozusagen auf einem großen Tisch von Problemen dann nur noch ein weiteres ist. Und dann wissen die schon Bescheid und können sich dann eben auch auf die Situation einstellen, dass es halt also wirklich dann eben Länder gibt, wo dann halt der Unternehmen irgendwas nicht zusammenschauen kann. Dann rennen sie eben weinend zum nächsten Sicherheitsdienst und der muss dann eben ihnen die Daten hacken. Also das ist eben wirklich, also wer einem sozusagen Schaden zufügt, das ist wirklich ein ureigenes Interesse herauszufinden, wer das ist. Und das gehört dann eben natürlich dazu, da diese Interessen in irgendeiner Form so gut geht zu bedienen. Oder im Zweifelsfall auch wirklich zu sagen, Leute, es ist zu lange her, diese Spuren sind weg. Und dann kommen dann eher Spezialisten dazu, die einfach sagen können, okay, was hat die Firma in der Zeit Interessantes gemacht? Aber das ist dann eben in dem Sinne kein Techniker mehr, sondern das ist eben jemand, der sich mit der Firma sehr gut auskennt und zweifelsfall mit dem Verhalten der Konkurrenz.
Ein sehr guter Punkt, den du angesprochen hast, weil in so einem Bericht gibt man üblicherweise Empfehlungen auch, wie man damit umgeht, wie man reagiert, was man für die Zukunft machen kann. Das sind in meinem Arbeitsbereich üblicherweise die spannenden Dinge, dass wir dann sagen, wir haben das und das entdeckt, wir empfehlen damit folgendermaßen umzugehen, z.B. schalte alle Rechner ab und mache eine genauere Analyse. Dann haben die Führungskräfte in der Situation immer die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wir wollen von diesen drei Vorschlägen, die ihr jetzt gemacht habt, das auswählen und dann ist der eine vielleicht der radikale, wo man alle Rechner runterfährt und der andere ist, wie wir schon vorhin besprochen haben, der Vorschlag, wir lassen das jetzt noch weiter laufen und gucken uns an. Wir versuchen da halt auch üblicherweise, bei mir sind es meistens Firmen, die zum Angriff betroffen sind und die brauchen natürlich Hilfe. Wir verstehen deren Geschäft nur in groben Zügen, weil wir das ja gerade erst kennengelernt haben. Und da ist dann halt immer dieses Entscheiden, was denn jetzt das Richtige ist. Ein Prozess, der zwischen beiden passiert.
Aber es ist sozusagen standardmäßig schon so, dass genug Verständnis dafür da ist, dass genau das passieren kann.
Also wir sagen es mal so, wenn das eine Organisation ist, die eigentlich auch historisch schon, also noch vielleicht bevor überhaupt Computer eine Rolle gespielt haben, wusste, dass es so etwas wie Industrie-Spionage, Konkurrenzspionage gibt, dann ist es natürlich für die nicht überraschend. Aber heutzutage, wir haben ja ein bisschen so dieses, überall zieht so dieses amerikanische Management-System ein, das ein Manager erst mal primär sich selbst schützt. Das heißt, der mag dann schon, der mag vielleicht dieses Verständnis haben, aber es kann sein, dass er dieses Verständnis nicht anwendet, weil einfach sein Ziel nur ist, möglichst gut aus der Situation rauszukommen. Und wenn das natürlich die Unternehmenskultur ist, dann ist das für alle Beteiligten, also wirklich vom sozusagen, vom ganz normalen Administrator bis sozusagen zu den Sicherheitsleuten, dann ist das für alle Beteiligten natürlich enorm anstrengend, weil so eine Organisation, die will das Verständnis gar nicht haben.
Na gut, das bleibt spannend. Ich würde es noch mal andersherum fragen, Hakan, ihr habt jetzt einen Podcast über das Thema gemacht. Und da muss es ja dann nicht nur verständlich für die EntscheiderInnen sein, sondern da gibt es ja auch noch zu sagen eine mutmaßliche Zielgruppe, die man bedienen muss, will, soll. Wie viel Arbeit, Nacharbeit, Mehrfachüberarbeitung des Kriptes hat das denn gebraucht, um dieses ganze komplexe System so aufzuarbeiten, dass es dann zufriedenstellend für alle war?
Also ich glaube dadurch, dass weder Florian noch ich einen Background in Informatik haben. Also ich kann ein bisschen programmieren und so weiter, aber das Einmaleins check ich vielleicht, aber die Sachen, über die wir dann berichten, sind ja dann schon sehr hardcore spezifisch gewesen. Das ist dann meistens so, dass ich Gespräche einfach dreimal für viermal für und die Geduld und Nettigkeit der Leute, die mit uns reden, krass strapaziere, um es dann auf eine Art und Weise zu erzählen, dass es technisch akkurat ist und passt und irgendwie spannend ist hoffentlich. Und dann haben wir in dem konkreten Fall tatsächlich das anderen Leuten vorgelesen und haben geguckt, an welchen Stellen stolpern die, an welchen Stellen kommen die nicht mit und dann noch einmal noch mehr Leuten vorgelesen, nachdem wir es überarbeitet haben und nach zweimal Vorlesen war klar, okay, so müsste das jetzt ungefähr passen und trotzdem irgendwie spannend genug sein, dass es auch die Leute hören wollen, die die technischen Details interessieren. Also beide Leute, beide Gruppierungen zu erreichen, meines Ziels. Ich hoffe, dass es geklappt hat.
Na gut, davon müsst ihr euch selber ein Bild machen. Genau, ich würde an dieser Stelle zum Ende kommen wollen, fand es sehr spannend. Oder vielleicht letzte Frage noch an alle und wir machen nochmal eine Runde. Weil wir jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber geredet haben, wie Leute in Systeme einbrechen und was alles für fütterliche Dinge passieren können. Und wie schwierig das alles ist, dagegen vorzugehen. Wird es schlimmer? Also müssen wir uns darauf einstellen, alle Systeme werden für immer gehackt, es sei denn gezielt, weil wir Spionagedings sind oder als Beifang, weil irgendwas unsicher war. Oder ist das sozusagen eine Entwicklung? Also ja, es wird immer Probleme geben, aber es wird jetzt nicht maßgeblich schlimmer oder nicht. Was ist da euer Eindruck? Vollkorn und Wolpertwo aus der Arbeit, Hakan, vielleicht sozusagen nach dem Podcast.
Ich fange mal kurz an, weil IT-Security so allgemein, ich habe das Gefühl, vor irgendwie 20 Jahren, als das Feld groß wurde, da haben ganz viele Leute die Einstellung gehabt, wir machen jetzt IT-Security, aber das wird nicht lang gehen, weil wir werden bald alles abgesichert haben und dann haben wir uns selber in unserem Job obsolet gemacht. Und das stellt sich jetzt als leichter Tugschluss raus. Und immer mehr habe ich den Eindruck, man kann so viele Leute auf dieses Problem werfen, wie man möchte, es gibt einfach genug zu tun, es ist ein absolutes Mangelfeld, also man findet nicht genügend Leute für die IT-Security, Forensik und all solche Sachen. Und es wird einfach immer mehr, es wird nicht weniger, so sage ich das mal lieber, was es zu tun gibt. Es verändert sich zwar, die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen werden besser, die Betriebssysteme, die Cold-Qualität von Microsoft zum Beispiel hat sich seit den letzten 20 Jahren deutlich verbessert und solche Dinge. Aber es kommt auch immer mehr neue Komplexität, neue Angriffsflächen hinzu, neue Angriffstechniken. Man spürt halt auch, dass durch die besseren Sicherungsmaßnahmen die Angreiferinnen einen höheren Druck haben und kreativer werden. Und neue Konzepte sich überlegen. Also ich glaube, da wird sich viel verändern und es wird die ganze Zeit was passieren, aber es wird immer weitergehen.
Okay, wir werden nicht alle sterben. Nicht auf einmal zumindest, hoffentlich. Hakan, hat sich für dich nach dem Podcast das Verständnis von der IT-Sicherheit verändert?
Also ich finde dieses Thema Attribution wahnsinnig spannend. Und ich habe durch den Podcast, auch wenn ich mich in den Jahren zuvor immer damit beschäftigt habe, dadurch, dass ich den Luxus hatte, dass mein Arbeitgeber gesagt hat, schaust du dir einfach fünf Monate an, kann ich jetzt über dieses Thema Attribution auf eine Art und Weise reden, wo ich sage, okay, das finde ich in sich schlüssig, um deine eigentliche Frage zu beantworten. Ich habe schon den Eindruck, also es ist ein bisschen Zwiegespalten. Auf der einen Seite, Vollkorn hat es ja angedeutet, wenn man so Google-Produkte verwendet, kann man zu Google stehen, wie man will, aber Gmail ist einfach erstmal sicher. Oder Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung. Oder wenn man seine Systeme back-up-t und die aktuellsten Betriebssysteme verwendet, dann läuft man erstmal nicht Gefahr, direkt zwangsläufig gehackt zu werden. Auf der anderen Seite, dadurch, dass es diese krasse Monopolisierung gibt, lohnt es sich für die Hacker halt auch einfach, nach diesen Sicherheitsnücken zu gucken, weil wenn ich was bei Exchange gefunden habe, dann sind halt all diese Landschaften, in denen Microsoft eingesetzt wird, mit einem Schlag offen. Deswegen geht es so in beide Richtungen. Ich glaube aber, für Privatpersonen ist es viel, viel, viel einfacher geworden, die eigenen Systeme zu sichern. Einfach durch Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung alleine schon.
Wolpertwo, du zum Schluss auch noch?
Ja, also ich glaube, Zwei-Faktoren spielen da eine Rolle, die das teilweise eher schlechter machen. Das eine ist, dass die Renzenwehrgruppen beziehungsweise Leute mit Adressungsprojekten, die verdienen gerade Geld und ziehen damit natürlich auch andere Leute in den Bereich rein, weil die eben einfach damit sehen, dass man je nachdem, in welchem Land man arbeitet, mit einer erfolgreichen Operation halt mehr verdienen kann, wie wenn man dort das ganze Jahr arbeitet. Und wenn natürlich kriminelle Geld haben, dann machen sie natürlich, kaufen sich damit nicht nur Luxus, sondern sie investieren auch wieder. Also sie können mehr Exportautoren bezahlen. Sie können noch bequemere Arbeitsabläufe sich ausdenken. Und das spielt sicher gerade eine größere Rolle. Also das sorgt sicher für eine Verschlechterung der Situation. Und das andere ist auch, was Cloud-Technologien angeht, das ist auch ein bisschen deprimierend, weil das sind immer mehr so Sachen, in denen Sicherheit intransparent ist, weil die Hersteller überall alle normalen Fachbegriffe, die man aus der IT kennt, umbenennen, damit das eben so Alleinstellungsmerkmale sind. Also wer zum Beispiel weiß, was ein Microsoft-Blob ist. Und da ist es dann eben so, dass das eben oft sehr intransparent ist. Und gerade so bei den Angriffen rund um Solarwines, Hersteller von Netzwerkechnologie, da hat es eben auch viele Opfer gegeben, unter anderem Sicherheitsunternehmen, die sind alleine deswegen gehackt worden, weil sie sich eigentlich mit normaler Sicherheit gut auskennen, aber tatsächlich eben offensichtlich ihre Cloud-Technologien einfach nicht genug verstanden haben. Und das sind natürlich auch Sachen, die sind auf Verkauf getrimmt. Und auch Microsoft bemüht sich da natürlich, dass man das eben sicher machen kann. Aber kaufen tut man es erstmal in einem unsicheren Zustand. Und das ist halt das Problem für jedes Unternehmen, was keine eigene Sicherheitsabteilung ist. Das ist eben davon abhängig, dass Software und Systeme im Auslieferungszustand eben sicher sind. Und da haben wir meiner Meinung nach in dem Bereich, da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt nur Rückschritte. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt Wahlcomputer in die Cloud, dann würde ich mir wirklich so schnell wie möglich die nächste Alkoholquelle suchen.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, ich glaube für den optimistischen Ausblick hat man das Chaosradio noch nie gehört. Also Hakan, Vollkorn, Wolpertwo, vielen Dank, dass ihr heute da wart und so ausführlich Rede und Antwort gestalten habt zu diesem doch überraschenden, nicht so ganz einfachen Thema. Aber wir konnten vielleicht eine kleine Einführung geben. Vielen Dank euch nochmal. Und das war Folge 268 des Chaosradios. Nächsten Monat geht es wahrscheinlich um eine sehr wichtige Technologie, die man sogar fünffach übereinander stapeln kann. Mehr möchte ich an dieser Stelle noch nicht sagen. Nur noch eins, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.